en el vídeo pasado habíamos logrado
simplificar nuestra expresión del error
cuadrática a esta expresión de aquí era
el error cuadrática de la línea a los n
puntos también habíamos comenzado a
visualizarlo como una superficie en tres
dimensiones entonces lo pensábamos de la
siguiente forma para cada mb había un
punto sobre la superficie que
representaba el error cuadrática para
esa línea
la meta era encontrar la m y la b osea
encontrar una recta de tal forma que se
minimice el error cuadrática la forma en
la que dijimos que vamos a hacer esto es
que vamos a encontrar un punto en donde
se anulen las derivadas parciales con
respecto a m y con respecto a b ok
entonces eso en la figura se vería como
que no cambian m
o sea que si nos movemos en esta
dirección la pendiente es 0 déjame
hacerlo con el mismo color con el verde
entonces la pendiente en esta dirección
la parcial con respecto a m es 0 y
igualmente la pendiente con respecto a b
o sea la pendiente en esta dirección es
igual a 0 en otras palabras la parcial
con respecto a b es igual a 0 muy bien
eso de ahí
punto mínimo vamos a encontrar la m y la
b que nos dan estas parciales igual a
cero ahora para sacar la parcial de esta
expresión con respecto a m vamos a ir
poco a poco con cada uno de los sumandos
el primero no tiene m entonces es
constante desde visto desde el punto de
vista de m como pequeño recordatorio
sacar parciales es lo mismo que sacar
derivadas pero estamos pensando que todo
excepto la variable con respecto a la
cual estamos sacando la parcial es
constante entonces en esta expresión las
x es leyes ves y en es todas estas son
constantes la única variable para la
parcial es m bueno entonces esto de aquí
es una constante porque no tiene m el
segundo sumando es un término lineal
estamos derivando con respecto a m y por
tanto la derivada de este término con
respecto a m es menos dos veces es el
coeficiente de la m verdad es menos 12 n
por el promedio de los productos de los
xy esto de aquí es la parcial de este
término con respecto a m ahora en este
término de acá pues tampoco tenemos ms
entonces es constante desde el punto de
vista de m
entonces su parcial es igual a cero
ahora acá tenemos un término cuadrática
nm entonces es m cuadrada n por el
promedio de las x es cuadradas de modo
que puedes sacando la parcial el 2 baja
nos quedaría más dos veces y luego aquí
vamos a ponerlo así n por el promedio de
las x es cuadradas y luego x m verdad
simplemente lo que hicimos es saber la
derivada de m cuadrada es dos veces m y
luego tenemos esta constante un
coeficiente constante en este término
rojito también tenemos una m y otra vez
es lineal entonces simplemente nos
quedaría puedes más 2 b n por el
promedio de las x es muy bien para
agarrarle más la onda es como cuando
derivar 3x y te queda 3 es exactamente
la misma idea
finalmente el término nv no tiene m por
tanto es constante y su derivada
parciales 0 listo esta es la parcial del
error con respecto a m y queremos que
sea igual a 0 muy bien ahora hagamos lo
mismo para la parcial con respecto a b
este término una vez más es constante
el punto de vista debe no hay ningún ave
aquí tampoco hay de estas dos parciales
nos quedan igual a cero en ninguna y ve
en el tercer sumando tenemos menos 2 b n
por el promedio de las es entonces nos
queda que la parcial de ese término es
menos dos veces n x el promedio de las
yes muy bien acá no hay b en el término
rojito tenemos una veces más 2 bcm n por
el promedio de las x es 2 m n 2 m n por
el promedio de las x es esto
esencialmente es el coeficiente de este
término lineal misma idea derivamos con
respecto a b 7 b entonces la deriva de 7
es exactamente la misma idea verdad
simplemente ponemos el coeficiente del
término lineal y finalmente tenemos la
parcial del último término que nos
quedaría dos veces
nb es más dos veces dos veces que dije
así b n
o nb bueno es lo mismo eso de ahí
queremos que sea igual a cero muy bien
ahora parece que nos queda un poquito
complicado el sistema pero recuerda que
sólo queremos encontrar m&b observa que
son dos ecuaciones y dos variables hay
ms
m ya que hay vez y tenemos vez entonces
es un sistema lineal de ecuaciones y
para ver qué es todavía más sencillo
tanto el de arriba como el de abajo son
divisibles entre 12 ene entonces podemos
dividir ambas ecuaciones entre 12 ene y
así simplificar a ver si dividimos lo de
arriba entre 12 ene esto se convierte en
un 1 este de aquí también se hace un 1
este 2 con este n también se hace uno
entonces simplemente nos quedaría menos
el promedio de las equis y es del
producto de las x es más
m por el promedio de las x es cuadradas
a jaime por el promedio de las x es
cuadradas + b por el promedio de las x
es ajá y eso es igual a 0 verdad eso de
ahí es la primera ecuación dividido
entre 12 n y en la segunda tenemos algo
similar este se cancela arriba dividimos
entre 12 n verdad o sea no entre menos 2
en entre 2 n aquí abajo dividiendo entre
12 n
estos se cancelan todos estos se
cancelan y solo nos queda menos el
promedio de las es más más m por el
promedio de las x es baja m por el
promedio de las x es más b es igual a
cero ok entonces si encontramos la mlb
que satisface en este sistema de
ecuaciones obtendremos donde se anulan
las parciales y por tanto donde se
minimice el error cuadrática ahora
podríamos resolverlo de la forma
tradicional pero déjame antes pasar por
algo interesante vamos a ver qué quiere
decir estas expresiones en términos de
la recta ideal entonces lo que voy a
hacer es sumar el promedio de las x ya
está acá arriba entonces vamos a sumar
el promedio de las
aquí y aquí en la ecuación verde y que
obtenemos a ver obtenemos m por el
promedio de las x es cuadradas más veces
el promedio de las x es
y eso es igual a los de la izquierda se
cancelan esto es igual a el promedio de
los productos de las equis y es muy bien
eso de ahí es la ecuación verde ahora la
con la ecuación azul si sumamos el
promedio de las yes aquí y acá esto se
cancela y entonces nos queda que n no lo
voy a hacer en azul para ser consistente
con los colores m por el promedio de las
x es más b más b es igual a es igual a y
aquí nos queda bueno el promedio de las
yes ok para poder decir algo en términos
de la recta ideal quiero pasar ambas
ecuaciones a la forma mx más ve igual
hay por ejemplo la de abajo ya está en
esta forma porque quiero hacer esto
pues mira supongamos que nuestra línea
óptima ya está dada por e iguala mx más
b donde la m y la b ya son óptimas ahora
está m y esta vez son las mismas m y ve
que satisfacen el sistema de ecuaciones
justo por eso podemos concluir que la
línea óptima o sea la que mejor se
ajusta con
al punto y esto es algo que viene de la
segunda ecuación contiene al punto deja
lo escribo por aquí contiene al punto
que tiene a los promedios no mejor voy a
escribirlo de esta manera el punto
promedio de las x es coma promedio de
las es esta
esta recta o sea en esta línea esto lo
leí directamente de acá arriba o sea
hacia aquí en la ecuación pongo en vez
de x el promedio de las x es por la
segunda ecuación obtenemos el promedio
de las yes esto de aquí está muy
interesante miraba manos arriba para
acordarnos del contexto entonces
teníamos puntitos y había dibujado la
recta óptima
lo que estamos diciendo es que esta
recta que es la óptima así la mejor de
todas va a tener al punto cuya primera
coordenada es el promedio de todos los
valores de x y su segunda coordenada es
el promedio de todos los valores de y
eso está súper interesante y de hecho
más o menos es intuitivo o sea que la
mejor recta tenga al promedio no es algo
tan extraño y con esto de que tenga el
promedio me refiero a que tiene al punto
cuyas entradas son los promedios de los
datos que nos dan ahora de modo similar
vamos a ver qué información en este
sentido nos da la primera ecuación vamos
a ver si la primera ecuación también nos
da información acerca de algún punto que
esté sobre la recta para esto primero
tenemos que pasarla a la forma m x + b
entonces vamos a dividir entre el
promedio de las x es y si hacemos esto
obtendríamos que m multiplicado por el
promedio de las x es cuadradas dividido
entre el promedio de las x es
+ b es igual al promedio de las xy es
dividido entre el promedio de las x es
muy bien entonces cuando lo escribimos
de esta forma es la misma ecuación pero
simplemente la dividimos entre el
promedio de las x es entonces obtenemos
otro punto interesante que cae en la
línea óptima en la recta óptima que
estamos encontrando vale cómo le hacemos
para jalar esta información pues lo
escribimos por acá déjame ponerlo en
color verde para seguir siendo
consistente con los colores y entonces
el punto va a ser el punto este de aquí
así que la coordenada en x va a ser el
promedio de las x es cuadradas dividido
entre el promedio de las x es y en la
coordenada que va a tener el promedio de
las xy es dividido entre el promedio de
las x es ba después vamos a pensar un
poquito más en qué quiere decir esto
pero bueno entonces ya tenemos dos
puntos que caen sobre la línea déjame
escribirle por aquí
está sobre sobre pues la mejor línea
sobre la línea que más se ajusta
la mejor línea basada en pues en este
criterio que es el error cuadrática la
mejor línea según el error cuadrática
bueno en el siguiente vídeo y con esto
ya aparece una saga sin fin verdad ya
está aparece la historia interminable
pero bueno en el siguiente vídeo lo que
vamos a hacer es ya terminar de resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones y todavía no
me decidido si con álgebra o con una
interpretación geométrica a lo mejor lo
hagamos de las dos formas pero creo que
ahorita ya estoy un poco cansado para
intentar eso bueno ya veremos hasta la
próxima